[Music]
well it's time to start the afternoon
session seems to me Lee has given me too
much work to do today
but I I'd like to take a few minutes to
talk about the Center for Theoretical
Physics which is the title of this
session as I see since everyone is
reminiscing permit me a few minutes of
it I came back here after having been a
graduate student in 1956 the same year
that Francis Lowe came from Illinois at
that time Sidney drell had been the
assistant professor and I think he had
already left
and Felix Villars was here as a maybe
assistant professor at that time too
plus Vicki and Herman and Francis
Friedman may have been around and
remember that but there was it was a
small group which was very nice we
didn't as I remember it as a young man
we didn't interact that much but it was
it was still a pleasant place to be but
it was small in 1960 I went to Paris for
a year and had some time to think about
things and remembered my experience in
Copenhagen where I had been from 54 to
56 and I came back in 61 with the
burning idea that MIT wasn't taking
advantage of Vicky and Herman I mean
they were the great men and they had
just a few people around them and there
was an opportunity to create something
here and so I started beating on both of
them I guess I remember around 62 it
took a few years but Peter demos was the
director of the lab agreed that it was a
good idea and we started to build up a
nuclear group and then when Vicky came
back from CERN
we had had some success building up the
nuclear group got some postdocs and so
on and the idea which we had been
thinking about to make it into a bigger
thing including how both high energy and
nuclear came to fruition
Nicky suggested that we really go to the
Institute and do something big and
thanks to his efforts and Herrmann's we
got the center started in 1967 the
Institute was very forthcoming it gave
us enough money to build that beautiful
area that we've got that people were
very jealous about as I remember and
people still do remark on because it was
a nice job architecture Lee and it
certainly has given us a beautiful home
Herman was the first director of the
Center for some years and then he became
department head after Vicki and Francis
came in as director Francis takes the
position I'm not sure he's here but he
takes the position that you stay in a
job only a few years and then you quit
and he did and I became director which
and I lasted a lot longer not taking
that position yes he became Provost
later we took the same position stayed
for five years and was out we now have
John niggly as director he's really
pulled it together in a way that I think
none of us did before in terms of
organization and real attention to
detail I think that the idea and the
fact that we did it has really paid app
and paid off I mean the center has
published I don't know a couple of
thousand publications since we started
keeping record and it's been a center
really has been a center people have
come from all around the world and
really very happy about the way it has
turned out and I hope it continues into
the future we're hearing from people who
have been associated with the center
this afternoon I know are in it some of
them our first speaker
is Roman jockey who's been here quite a
while I really can't remember the date
but it's been a pleasure having him here
particularly for me because off and on
we have collaborated a bit and that's
always been great to have to pay
attention to Roman when you could say
well where's the beef and everything we
ever did and it's a pleasure to
introduce Roman
so thank you the title I chose is
surprising successes of quantum field
theory and perhaps the greatest surprise
about field theory is that today it
continues to provide the only framework
for discussing successfully dynamical
issues of fundamental physics I was
looking for a numerology that might
render significant the peculiar 46th
anniversary that we hear celebrating and
the only coincidence I could come up
with was a sort of dyslexic calendrical
one and 1864 is when historians date the
birth of field theory this is of course
Maxwell's electromagnetic field theory
which has survived indeed one can say
which has precipitated the two
revolutions of 20th century physics
relativity in quantum mechanics in its
quantum version electromagnetism has
been verified with fantastic precision
and the generalization that
electromagnetism suggested the non
abelian yang-mills theory is an
ingredient together with quark and
lepton field theories in the standard
model of elementary particles and that
field theory the standard model of
elementary particles gives a flawless
account of the relevant experimental
data up to the present time now the
standard model is the most recent
triumph of field theory and parts of it
were put together at MIT led at LNS by
Steve Weinberg and he is here and
doubtlessly you will hear from him about
that tomorrow so I need not dwell on it
in fact the success of the standard
model has left very little for quantum
field theories to do in fundamental
physics and some have decamped the
subject returned to the s-matrix program
in its newest incarnation string theory
Gabriele Veneziano developed that
departure again at MIT Elin SCTP and he
will describe it later other field
theorists have turned to unexpected
topics and I want to describe to you
here one such unexpected investigation
an investigation which is unexpected on
two counts first of all it's unexpected
that a particle physicist might work on
it and the second reason it's unexpected
is one doesn't even think that a
scientist can work on this but perhaps
it's appropriate for this commemorative
event so to travel into the past to
observe the past perhaps to influence it
to correct the mistakes of one's youth
has been mankind's abiding fantasy for
as long as we've been aware of a past
and today I want to describe to you some
modern investigations of this topic
which are being carried out at MIT at
LNS now before the 20th century time
travel was discussed only in works of
fiction and among the innumerable
authors - are surely familiar Mark Twain
HG Wells and in fact Welles marks a
transition he was a graduate of London's
Imperial College of Science and
Technology and because of this 19th
century scientific enthusiasm he couched
his novel the time machine in a
scientific language and this gave us an
early work of science fiction
so Welles marks the traditional
transition between fiction and science
after 1900 it became possible to discuss
time machine scientifically and the
reason it became possible to discuss
time machine scientifically was because
of the development of special relativity
and the question may be posed in this
way it makes absolutely perfect good
sense and we would all agree that it
makes perfect good sense to speak of
traveling
to speak of traveling and returning to
the same point in space but since
Einstein tells us that space and time
are equivalent a natural question then
is can we after a journey return to the
same position in time if we can return
to the same position in space in space
and time are equivalent perhaps it
should be possible to return to the same
position and time this question was
analyzed and answered in fact many years
ago and what what what is established is
first of all recognizing that the
space-time with which special relativity
deals that is to say ordinary the old
ordinary flat Minkowski space-time it is
flat and rigid and time travel in fact
is possible but it requires faster than
light velocities and one can think of
this result the result which was
obtained the result that you can travel
into the past if you can travel at a
velocity faster than light you can think
of that result as a continuation of the
familiar time dilation story
the familiar time dilation story of
special relativity and that story begins
with the statement that if you start
from rest the faster you go the slower
flows time that statement continues with
the observation that if you go at the
velocity of light time stands still and
then the next extrapolation which is
mathematically correct is that if you
could go faster than the velocity of
light you would go backwards in time
however there are no known objects that
go faster than light and therefore time
machines cannot be constructed with the
physics and engineering possibilities
provided by special relativity however
it could be stressed that there is no
logical prohibition against exceeding
light velocity and indeed physical
consistency of a hypothetical world
in which there are objects traveling
faster than light these objects are
called tachyons the physical consistency
of such a world was established and even
tachyons were looked for experimentally
experiments were performed to see
whether one could find any trace of
objects traveling faster than light and
none were found
there are no tachyons as best as we can
tell time travel based on tachyons is
not possible and the entire subject was
summarized by Gary Feinberg almost 20
years ago late of Columbia University
and that sort of ends the discussion of
time travel based on special relativity
but then we come to general relativity
again Einsteins work and now the
space-time which was rigid and flat in
the special relativistic context the
space-time is no longer fixed and it can
take on all kinds of unexpected
geometrical shapes and the nature of
space-time is determined by the content
of the matter content of the universe
and in particular for some special weird
forms of matter there can be geometries
which permit time travel into the past
with velocity that is less than the
velocity of light and if you can find a
geometry which permits travel into the
past the technical phrase is that the
geometry possesses closed time light
curves closed time light curves are
paths in this flexible geometry of
general relativity which permits one to
travel into the past at velocities less
than the velocity of light now the first
solution to Einstein's theory with
closed timelike curves was obtained in
1949 by girdle and it permits
construction of time machines and this
solution which riddle obtained caused
great puzzlement and the reason it
caused great puzzlement because first of
all
there is no experimental evidence of
people traveling in time we don't have
any visitors from the future visiting us
here in their past and second of all our
notions of causality which to be sure
are already challenged by quantum
mechanics but still they're with us long
enough and strongly enough that they
prejudice us against considering
geometries with closed timelike curves
were effect proceed causes
so although girdles solution was
certainly a fact it caused great
resistance in the physics and
mathematics community it encountered
great resistance in the physics and
mathematics community but upon further
reflection it's clear that Einstein's
equations of general relativity will
always permit some kinds of solutions
which possess this closed timelike
curves and the reason for that is
because the structure of Einstein's
equations could you lower that a little
bit yeah just lower it yeah
the structure of Einstein's equations is
that the distribution of matter
determines the space-time geometry on
the other hand we don't really have any
uh priori ideas about what the
distribution of matter should be so what
we could do is run the equation in the
other direction let's just take a
geometry for space-time which permits a
time machine plug like geometry into the
Einstein equations and come up with a
formula for the matter which will
support that solution and in that way
one can say one has found a time machine
solution to be sure one has founded by
construction but still it is a
legitimate bona fide solution of
Einstein's equations there were
reactions to arch the girdle solution
into all these other possible solutions
and here is Einsteins own reaction he
mentions that Kurt girdles time machine
solution raises for him the problem
which he thought about already
when he thought of the theory forty
years earlier and without really being
able to resolve the problem the problem
being how do you prevent the theory from
predicting time machines and then just a
few years ago
Hawking commented on girdle solution and
once again he says girdle presents a
solution which is the first to be
discovered in which it's possible to
travel into the past this leads to
paradoxes what happens if you go back
and kill your father when he was a baby
and then he says what people always say
it is generally agreed that this cannot
happen in a solution that represents our
universe but you was the first to show
that it was not forbidden by Einstein's
equation and his solution as I mentioned
generated a lot of discussion of the
relation between general relativity and
the concepts of causality so as you see
our defense as well as Einsteins and
Hawking's against these solutions and
against the puzzles that they entail is
to assert that their unphysical they to
be excluded in physical grounds but they
are unphysical in the sense that one
asserts that the matter distribution
which gives rise to a time machine
geometry one simply asserts that the
matter distribution which gives rise to
a time machine geometry is unphysical
so girdle when he found his solution the
matter distribution that he used was a
uniform energy density in all of space
and we can of course see that that is
not the situation in our universe so in
that sense we can say girdle solution is
unphysical these days one hears of time
machines being studied at Caltech by Kip
Thorne and his colleagues and these time
machines make use of wormholes wormholes
is another exotic and presumably on
physical form of matter where there is a
tiny little channel in space-time that
connects the past in the future and
through this channel there
runs a closed timelike curve and once
again one could say well mathematically
that's true the that peculiar form of
matter implies time machine geometry but
one could say on physical grounds
perhaps we can exclude that after all we
don't really see any evidence for such
wormholes now the reason for the current
activity in this subject derives from
the recent realization that another form
of matter called cosmic strings supports
closed timelike curves so first of all i
have to tell you what are causing
extremes now cosmic strings are
hypothetical but entirely physical
structures that may have survived from a
cosmic phase transition and can be
responsible for the present-day
large-scale structure in the universe
only completely conventional physical
ideas are relied upon in cosmic string
speculations and completely conventional
astrophysicists and cosmologists make
you make use of these ideas in building
theories some astrophysicists
occasionally even report sightings of
cosmic strings but thus far evidence has
been inconclusive nevertheless one could
not view cosmic strings as unphysical
the fluctuations in the temperature that
we did lead to the Harrison Zelda which
spectrum that so much talked about these
days cosmic string proponents maintain
that cosmic strings can give rise to
that and that can be another example of
the physical acceptability of the
concept of cosmic strings and therefore
if indeed cosmic strings give rise to
closed timelike curves there is
something new that we physicists have to
confront and explain because we would
not want to say that cause and extremes
are an unphysical form of matter so the
first thing I have to do for you is to
describe to you in a little bit greater
detail the geometry of space and of
space-time that is caused by cosmic
strings and we'll think of a cosmic
string as a kind of defect like a vortex
line in space let's say along the z axis
and this this this is like a defect it's
like a defect in helium which survived
after a cosmic phase transition but it
sits in the universe there and it has a
certain mass density per unit length and
if it has that mass density per unit
length we can then say it's a form of
matter we can stick this form of matter
into the Einstein equation and determine
the geometry of space-time that this
form of matter creates and the geometry
of space-time that it creates is in fact
very simple there is no structure in
time so I didn't even bother drawing the
time axis here along the axis of the
cosmic strain also there is no structure
the only interesting structure is in the
plane perpendicular to the cosmic string
and the structure in this perpendicular
plane is very interesting indeed in fact
that plane is flat it's just like the
surface that I'm standing on here
however if you go around the cosmic
string you don't go around 2 pi degrees
but you go around less there's a certain
amount of missing space which this
cosmic string causes and this missing
space the amount of space the angular
amount of space which is missing is
proportional to the mass per unit length
of this string so that is the geometry
of a cosmic string and in a sense it's
analogous to the physics and the
presence of a magnetic field a constant
magnetic field you know that charged
particles moving in a constant magnetic
field along the z axis have non-trivial
motion really only in the plane
perpendicular to that z axis and one can
just focus on the physics
in that plane and that kind of focus is
the subject of Landau theory of the Hall
effect quantum Hall effect of high TC
superconductors well an analogous story
can be told gravitationally and they're
the cosmic string plays the role of the
magnetic field and then the interesting
physics is confined to the plane
perpendicular and it is confined and and
and the only interesting thing about
that plane is that even though it is
flat as if there were no cosmic string
there is some amount of missing space
now in the next transparency I'm gonna
draw the space-time and now what I've
done is I've suppressed the z-axis I
can't draw four axis on a plane so I've
suppressed the z-axis here is the cosmic
point now that's that's what's left of
the cosmic string here is time as I
promised you it's it's sort of
structural is it just goes up and down
and here is the plane perpendicular with
its missing deficit angle and here is
the world line of the cosmic string it
provided it's stationary so it's not
moving it's just it just stands at the
same place and time flows nicely and
uniformly now this is a spinless cosmic
string the only attribute this cosmic
string has is mass per unit length but
now we could give the cosmic string
another attribute we could also give it
some spin so we now contemplate about a
cosmic string that is not only carrying
a mass per unit length but carries a
spin per unit length and then we ask
what is the space-time that such a
spinning cause an extreme produces and
that space-time is a picture very
similar to the previous one except time
where before was just freely flowing
from minus infinity to plus infinity
now acquires a helical structure and the
picture of this helix is proportional to
the spin per unit length now this
becomes rather technical and
mathematical here is not
to give the detail account just let me
assure you that this helical structure
has the consequence that it is possible
to find closed timelike curves and it is
possible to construct time machines so
spinning cosmic strings give rise to
time machines and this is a result which
was established actually some years ago
and a result which one can still escape
from because one can say well although
cosmologists make use of cosmic strings
they only make use of spinless cosmic
strings and we could say that a spinning
cosmic string is unphysical and
consequently once again there's no real
reason to think about these closed
timelike curves that are created if you
have a spinning cosmic string however
last year Richard God had Princeton
asked the following question suppose you
have two cosmic strings each one
spinless but each one moving with a
velocity relative to the other so that
the entire system possesses angular
momentum it is to be understood that
what calls the closed timelike curve was
the angular momentum and in the first
example the angular momentum was simply
carried on that single string as
intrinsic spin and that maybe is
unphysical but now we're going to have
spin lifts strings that have that all
the cosmologists would like to have and
we're going to let them move which we
didn't do before
certainly the cosmologists want their
strings to move and once they cut the
string is moving then there's going to
be angular momentum in this system and
the question arises will there be a
closed timelike curve and will this
allow the construction of a time machine
so here is the very schematic drawing
here is one cosmic string here's another
next ring here is the missing space of
one here's the missing space of the
other and now it shouldn't come as a
surprise if I tell you that if a light
path goes from A to B this is sort of
speaking the direct line then another
light path which goes from A to B but
surrounds the cosmic strings and
consequently doesn't really have to
traverse this missing area is missing
region of space because the space isn't
there that another light ray going on
this surrounding path can beat this
light ray and in fact this is possible
detailed analysis of this geometry shows
that you can beat a light ray and having
beaten a light ray you can construct a
closed timelike curve and once you can
construct a closed timelike curve you
can build a time machine and so mr. God
correctly pointed out that two cosmic
strings moving with a certain velocity
will produce a closed timelike
but of course the velocity has to exceed
a certain minimal velocity because we
know for example that if the cosmic
strings are standing still in spin lists
then nothing will happen so this there
is a critical velocity that has to be
exceeded
but this critical velocity that each
string has to exceed is less than the
velocity of light and therefore it
appears that one can construct a time
machine using completely acceptable
physical ideas and constructs now this
discussion by god produced great
interest because for the first time the
question of time machines became
scientifically physical and only awaited
the development of engineering
possibilities and the accounts of this
were carried in the popular and semi
popular press only this new scientist
and science are really accurate the
others make it sound as if it's going to
be built very soon the the practical
applications and and financial
possibilities were discussed however
also a bit fall in a business pitfall
and commercial development was noted in
the in the international in the in the
syndicated press and then we decided
that since the subject was so
interesting and so provocative we should
look into it further now there is of
course a catch and it's interesting to
find where the catch is what happens is
the following one needs a pair of moving
strings and each of the pair is non
tachyonic is moving with a velocity less
than the velocity of light but you can
ask what is the center of
energy of the pair so you have to add up
the energies of the individual strings
now the concept of energy is a concept
which is a conserved quantity which
arises from the fact that space-time
allows translations and because it
allows translations you have the concept
of energy but when the space-time is as
chewed up as it is in the presence of
cosmic strings the concept of energy
still exists but the addition laws for
combining it are highly non-trivial and
highly nonlinear and consequently when
you add the energies of the individual
non tachyonic strings you discover that
the total energy is that of a tachyon
and therefore even though the Princeton
construction was mathematically correct
it once again belongs into that category
of constructions which makes use of a
matter distribution which is unphysical
why is it unphysical because even though
each individual cosmic string is non
tachyonic the Assembly of two is
tachyonic and consequently they could
never be produced you might imagine for
example producing these cosmic strings
by the decay of something else and and
and and of course they cannot be
produced moving at that high velocity
which is required for closed cosmic
strings so that is the catch there is
the obstacle to God's time machine then
the velocity of light exceeds this
critical velocity we cannot do it in our
non tachyonic world
this was further investigated by further
colleagues and at LNS and our frequent
collaborators yarded hoofed and and and
confirming that for the time being at
least
we are still safe from time machines and
the most recent string inspired attempt
at violating causality doesn't survive
no further questions remain and motivate
for the study and one can ask why is one
actually studying this kind of subject
and the answers the first answer they're
kind of more more highfalutin answer is
that the concept of time is very poorly
understood in fundamental physical
theories we don't know what gives time
it's observed direction indeed the whole
car the whole notion of time is is is
puzzling in the context of general
relativity which tells us that the
space-time is unknown until the matter
distribution is known in the matter
distribution determines the space-time
so one wonders what is time before one
has the matter one hopes that studying
puzzling aspects of the theory like
these time machines will somehow give us
some clues about the nature of time in
physical theory but actually another
reason was the same one I mentioned at
the beginning that there is in fact very
little to do that is interesting in
fundamental physics owing to the
successes of the standard model and
therefore the present time some of us
are studying time itself thank you
you